Mark: My name's Mark Polliger, and I'm glad
to be hosting Professor Robert Mnookin today.
Professor Mnookin is the current Williston
professor of law at Harvard.
I think I got that right.
As well as the chair of a program on negotiation
there.
Which is dedicated to the study of the theory
of and the advancement of the practice of
negotiation.
Professor Mnookins latest studies and book
focus on negotiating under the challenging
condition when you see who you're negotiating
with as an adversary, or even as evil.
To do so requires specific techniques to arrive
at the best outcome while avoiding common
pitfalls that can sabotage you and the eventual
results.
The book is so new, published two days ago,
that we're among the first to hear about it
right from the source.
And after the talk, we will have some folks
we will have some folks from Books Inc. if
you want to order a copy of it with Google
subsidy and then you'll be able to pick it
up later and tell us more.
Please welcome Professor Robert Mnookin.
[Applause]
Robert: Thank you very much.
It's exciting to return to Silicon Valley
and be at Google.
[Pause]
And I have the good fortune of being in your
cafeteria.
I did that once before a couple years ago
with the general counsel of your company.
And some other googlers, and it's quite an
experience to look around for the checkout
counter where you pay,
[Laughter]
Robert: and find none.
I'm here to talk about my new book.
And the question I address in the book is,
should I bargain with the Devil?
By bargain, I mean try to resolve a conflict
through negotiation rather than resisting
or fighting.
And by Devil, I mean an adversary you don't
trust.
A person or organization who you think its
interests are opposed to your own, who may
be out to harm you.
An adversary you may even think is evil.
[Pause]
Robert: Now,
Robert: You can read in a newspaper everyday
about how relevant this question is.
For example right now, our national leaders
are really trying to figure out, should we
negotiate with the Taliban?
Or should we not?
It turns out that in 2001 after 9/11 President
Bush gave Mullah Omar an ultimatum.
Turn over Bin Laden and his compatriots and
shut down the training camps, or we're gonna
invade.
In fact, although this isn't very well known,
Mullah Omar's response at the time was let's
negotiate.
What's your evidence that Bin Laden was responsible
etc.
And President Bush said, "I'm not inviting
an negotiation, I mean this is an ultimatum."
And he went in.
Today, there's a new question.
Today should we be negotiating with Mullah
Omar who's in Pakistan or not?
Similarly with respect to Iran and North Korea.
There's been lots of discussion on what should
be the role of engagement and negotiation.
Google itself of course, with respect to the
issues your company faces in China.
Which in some respects in my view, in some
respects is an evil regime.
Poses analogous questions.
Now apart from these issues of high politics,
in business, there are now analogous issues
people often face.
For example, I've mediated a number of failed
joint ventures where a -- there's been a terrible
falling out between joint venture partners.
The question is, should you negotiate with
a joint venture partner who betrayed you?
If the competitor you believe is stealing
your intellectual property, should you fight,
or should you negotiate?
Indeed, one reason I was interested in writing
this books is I think there are analogous
problems that arise in families.
I've claimed that almost every family at least
if you're willing to go back a couple generations
and perhaps out to cousins.
Every family has a story of a family fight
over family property.
Sometimes the property is Grandma's engagement
ring.
Sometime it's a photographic album.
Sometimes it's a family business that has
to be divided up.
But there are any number of families that
-- curious out of -- raised -- hands raised.
How many of you know a family story where
family members aren't speaking to each other
anymore because of a fight over family property.
Well it looks like at least 30%, it's very
common.
Well, you have probably heard two arguments,
two extreme or categorical answers to the
question.
Should you bargain with the devil.
Now in my field, I share the program on negotiation
at Harvard, and I'm the head of what's called
the Harvard negotiation research project.
In my field, you've heard the categorical
answer.
And that is you should always negotiate.
You should always be prepared to sit down
in a problem solving way, see if you can work
out some arrangement that's better for you
and for the other side than litigation, much
less war.
It's an appealing argument, and you hear it
all the time.
You also hear the opposite kind of argument.
Less commonly in my zip code 02138 in Cambridge.
But that argument is really based on the fallacy
of legend.
And that is, you should never negotiate with
the devil, the devil's not to be trusted.
He may be smarter than you.
He's gonna certainly try to trick you, and
to negotiate risks soiling your soul, and
selling out principles that you should hold
dear.
It was not so long ago when after 9/11, Vice
President Dick Cheney declared, and I'm quoting,
"I have been charged by the president with
making sure that none of the tyrannies of
the world are negotiated with. We don't negotiate
with evil, we defeat it."
Well there's the two categorical answers.
Now I have to confess, I'm allergic to categorical
answers.
Because usually you can find a counter example
to embarrass a categorical claim.
And what I want you to think about for a moment,
who are your two greatest political heroes
of the 20th century.
Think about it to yourself.
[Pause]
Robert: 20th century.
I'm an old guy.
[Laughter]
This is a new century.
Here are my two greatest heroes, alright.
Winston Churchill is my hero because in May
of 1940 in Britain's darkest hour when France
was on the verge of collapse.
When the United States was uninvolved in the
war, and had not even begun Lend-Lease.
When the soviets had signed a pact with Germany
and were not in the war.
Churchill and his war cabinet faced the question
of whether they should accept an invitation
to have Mussolini mediate a negotiated resolution
of the war between Germany and Great Britain.
There were five days of secret discussions
in the war cabinet.
The minutes of those meetings are now available.
In his monumental post war -- after the war
history, Churchill wrote a multi-volume history
about World War II, he doesn't mention this
fact.
But in fact they struggled with the question
of whether to negotiate or not.
And Churchill, in my view appropriately decided
not to negotiate.
Although it turns out it's a very hard question,
and I have a chapter of the book about that.
My other hero, perhaps my greatest negotiation
hero is Nelson Mandela.
Mandela after being convicted and given a
life sentence for treason in 1985 having been
jailed already for more than 20 years secretly
initiated negotiations with the national party.
The Afrikaner party that had imposed the evil
apartheid regime.
I have a chapter about this episode to.
Mandela, although the most famous member of
the ANC was not in fact the head of the ANC.
That was Oliver Tombo who is in exile.
Moreover, the ANC in many ways ran on quite
collaborative principles.
And Mandela had a number of long time compatriots
jailed with him in the same prison.
In his memoir, Mandela struggled with the
question should I initiate negotiations given
the ANC's policy was against any form of negotiation
with the hated enemy.
And should I do so without consulting first
the ANC leadership or at least my compatriots
here.
He was able to smuggle information --things
in and out to Tombo, but it sometimes took
weeks.
And he candidly writes, "I decided it was
time to initiate negotiations, and I did so
without asking anyone. Why didn't I ask? Because
I knew what their answer would be. That is
I shouldn't negotiate."
So here you have my two great heroes.
One a hero because he refused to negotiate,
another a hero because he secretly initiated
negotiations.
And I ended up having thought about it, deciding
that the challenge of course is how do you
make wise decisions about whether to negotiate
or not if there aren't categorical answers
one way or the other.
And, the challenge I think is to make wise
decisions.
And what my book tries to do is offer a framework
for how to think through contextually in a
particular set of circumstances what a wise
decision would be.
And I do this though stories, eight real life
stories.
Two of them I've already mentioned, I'll briefly
mention some of the others a tad later in
my talk.
Because I think there's much to be learned
by assessing what others have done.
And trying to -- I asked myself if I applied
my framework, would I agree or disagree with
the particular decision?
[Pause]
Robert: Let me describe briefly one case that
is similar to a case I discuss in the book.
And that is, assume you are the C.E.O and
founder of a high-tech start up that's been
venture financed.
You're a research and development firm, you
don't manufacture devices yourself, you in
fact license it out.
Assume that you made a -- have a partner which
is the, I've changed the names needless to
say, the giant Bikouda Corporation.
A very large Japanese company that has licensed
your technology and know-how and has the right
to manufacture and distribute your medical
device.
But it promises that it won't distribute any
competing devices.
And you've given them a license for major
segments of the world, but not China.
You excluded China specifically.
You just discovered three years into a five
year joint venture agreement that secretly
the Bikouda Corporation has manufactured a
knock-off.
Slightly different, but not significantly
in your eyes at all.
A knock off of your product which it's selling
in China.
You confronted the head of the Bikouda Corporation
with your discovery, and he says -- he denies
that the product is violating any of your
rights.
And he says, besides you don't really understand
the Chinese market.
And by the way, your 15% royalty rate for
the rest of the world is too high, let's negotiate.
Maybe we'll negotiate a new agreement, maybe
we'll include China, but it's gotta be everything
at a much lower royalty rate.
What do you do?
Now in the kinds of conflicts I'm describing,
whether international or family or business,
emotions run high.
You are furious.
You feel treated -- you feel cheated rather.
You feel betrayed.
You're probably a little angry for yourself
for being so trusting.
The notion of negotiating turns your stomach.
You wanna fight.
How do you decide?
How do you make a wise decision?
Well luckily, there's someone who can help
you.
He's a Vulcan, his name is Mr.Spock.
Mr.Spock is logical, he's very analytical
and he has complete emotional detachment.
Indeed your spouse says he's a cold fish.
But he's prepared to advice you.
And in fact, in my book Mr.Spock suggests
some questions that you should ask yourself.
First he says you've gotta think hard about
what your underlying interests are, and what
the other side's interests are.
Second, very importantly, if you don't negotiate,
what are your alternatives away from the table?
Here perhaps you could sue.
Where are you gonna sue?
What is the probability of success?
Third, are there potential negotiated outcomes
that can better serve your interests than
your best alternative away from the table?
And also better serve the interests of your
adversary.
Because if you can't imagine any negotiated
outcomes that better serve the interests of
both sides, there's no reason to expect that
there's a very high probability you're gonna
be able to achieve a negotiated agreement.
Next, if you reach an agreement, assuming
you can imagine such an agreement, can it
be implemented?
Will it be enforceable?
Obviously the devil is someone you don't particularly
trust.
And finally, what are the costs of negotiation?
Negotiation itself isn't costless.
It may set a precedent, it may have reputational
consequences.
You've got to think about all these things.
Now, in this particular case, it turns out
you're legal alternative is not very good.
Suing in China would be impossible.
Suing in Japan, which is a possibility, is
very time consuming and slow.
And it's almost inconceivable that a Japanese
court would enjoin a Japanese company from
doing business in China.
The problem Spock points out, and your lawyer
has told you as much is it's not clear you
can get jurisdiction over the Bikouda Corporation
in California because they've never really
operated here very well.
You might, but you might not.
Spock thinks there's a 20% chance.
So what does Spock advise?
Spock advises you should contact your adversary,
you should indicate a willingness to negotiate.
But you should also indicate that if negotiations
don't work, or if -- you are gonna sue in
California.
And you should indicate to Bikouda Corporation
that its reputation in Silicon Valley -- because
you've heard via the grapevine that they are
interested in other joint ventures in the
United States.
Their reputation would plainly be damaged
by the mere fact of the lawsuit, and that's
something they'd want to take into account.
Now, what I talk about in the book are a series
of psychological traps that make it difficult
to think rationally about whether to negotiate
or to fight.
And let me just very briefly list some of
them and say a word about each.
One is demonization.
These traps are often present when people
are in intense conflict.
Demonization really is the notion the other
side's evil.
They're a bad person.
You're making judgments about their overall
character.
A second trap is tribalism.
It's our team against their team.
We're the insiders, they're the outsiders.
You don't usually trust the other side very
much.
Dehumanization, in the worst kinds of conflicts,
people don't even see their adversary as human.
Moralism, goodness and right is entirely on
my side.
I'm right, they're wrong, no grey.
The zero-sum fallacy is something that I talk
about all the time in negotiation.
Zero-sum fallacy is when I'm in conflict with
you, what I think is anything you win, I lose,
anything I win you lose.
You talk about zero-sum poc --mentality, the
zero-sum gremlin shrieking in people ears.
Look at what's going on in the United States
congress today between the Democrats and the
Republicans.
It's, it's it's as if anything that could
possibly benefit one party has to be bad for
the other party.
It's zero-sum.
The fight-flight fallacy, you know what that
is.
The call to battle is when the leader says
follow me, we're gonna charge ahead.
Now all of these things in my mind can really
get in the way of thinking clearly.
Apart from these traps though, I also want
to acknowledge what makes these kinds of cases
very difficult.
And that is there are considerations of legitimacy,
morality, identity and self respect.
It's quite possible that the C.E.O once he
calms down and really understood the opportunities
and risks of refusing to negotiate rather
than following Spock's strategy.
It's possible that the C.E.O could say, "Spock,
I understand what you're saying, but to negotiate
with this company after what they've done.
I'm not worried about my reputation with other
people, it's my reputation with myself.
It's inconsistent with the kind of person
I wanna be."
And often in terms of these issues, bargaining
with the devil, there is this problem.
And that is it really goes to a deep philosophical
question.
Are you prepared to be utilitarian and a consequencialist
that's gonna decide what to do by comparing
outcomes?
Or are there some values that you feel are
so important that you're willing to pay the
cost and take the risks?
Let me just say a word about the -- some of
the other chapters in the book, and then I'd
like to take some questions.
Rudolf Kastner was someone who decided to
negotiate with Adolf Eichmann in 1944.
Talk about bargaining with the devil.
Kastner wanted to do so in order to try to
save some Hungarian Jews.
He in fact succeeded through bribery in saving
1700 who were put on a train and ended up
going to Switzerland.
Tragically after the way he ended up going
to Israel, he was accused of collaboration.
There was a libel trial in which a trial court
judge wrote an awful opinion condemning him
for having sold his soul to the devil.
For having negotiated with Eichmann.
And having his own family members were among
the 1700 that made it on the train.
That decision was ultimately reversed by the
Israeli Supreme Court, but not before a right-wing
Israeli extremist assassinated him.
Very tragic story.
Another chapter is about someone else who
confronted an evil regime.
Natan Sharansky, he was a Refusenik in the
Soviet Union.
He refused to cooperate at all with the KGB.
The KGB signaled to him while he was in prison,
look, if you will denounce your cause, we'll
let you go, we'll let you emigrate to Israel
to join your wife.
And we know very well, I mean they were winking,
we know that once you get there, you'll say
that we coerced you, we understand that.
But what we want you to do is just sign here,
renouncing you cause.
He wouldn't do it.
And indeed when he was released finally in
a -- United States swapped a Soviet spy for
Sharansky some years after he'd been in jail
about 12 years.
The soviet agent that took him to East Berlin
where he was gonna be freed.
When they landed in Berlin said to him, "There's
a car waiting for you over there, you must
walk in a straight line between the plane
and the car."
And Sharansky said to this guy, "For 12 years,
I haven't done anything you've asked my to
do, why do you think I'll start now?"
And he walked in a crooked line.
[Laughter]
Robert: And, and, and got in the car.
I was the neutral in a huge dispute in the
late 80's between IBM and Fujitsu.
A chapter of the book is about that.
IBM believed that Fujitsu had stolen its operating
system.
And at the time, with its operating system,
Fujitsu had displaced within Japan IBM as
the top mainframe -- computer manufacturer.
This was in the age of the mainframe.
I had an extraordinarily interesting experience.
There was -- I assure you, much demonization
on both sides.
And I tell the story of this case.
I also did some work with the San Francisco
Symphony about a decade ago.
They had a catastrophic strike.
And someone from the Hewlett foundation called
me when I was on vacation, said, "Mnookin,
you gotta come here -- out here and teach
these people how to negotiate."
And there's nothing like being interviewed
for a job you don't think you want, but I
ended up doing it.
It was an extraordinarily interesting experience.
In fact I'm talking at the Commonwealth Club
on Friday, and some musicians and the people
I've worked with, some of them are gonna be
there.
It's a story with a reasonably happy ending.
I tell a story which doesn't have a very happy
ending about a terrible divorce where there
wasn't any negotiation.
And great damage to a child, to two children
caught in the middle.
And finally I tell a story -- another case
I was actually involved in involving a fight
over a beautiful Cape Cod waterfront property
that had been in the family for fifty or sixty
years.
It was inherited as tenants-in-common by three
siblings.
One of whom lived in the Bay area and wasn't
interested in -- just wanted to sell.
Another of the siblings thought this house
was their family, and was sort of profoundly
offended that she might try to force a sale.
Let me close by simply repeating my question,
should you bargain with the devil?
My answer is, not always.
But more often than you feel like.
More often than you feel like, and for two
different sorts of reasons.
First, because of these emotional and psychological
traps that can make it very painful.
And second, because in bargaining with the
devil, you often need to reach an agreement
that benefits the devil also.
And, which may involve in your mind the sacrifice
of principle on the altar of pragmatism.
That never feels too good.
Thank you very much, I'd be glad to take some
questions.
[Applause]
Mark: So thank you very much, very very good
talk.
There's a microphone over here.
People do have questions.
We are gonna be putting this up on YouTube.
So please use the mic and if you have questions
that we make sure that we get it recorded.
[Pause]
<< Hi, thanks for the talk.
There seems -- you've got a -- what seems
to be a dichotomy between either negotiation
vs. fight as you framed it.
Can you speak at all to tactics which are
used to build political power first as preludes,
potentially, preludes lasting years to build
up sufficient power to actually get to the
negotiating table.
I mean many of the great stories of non-violent
resistance are about that.
Where you don't start with negotiation, you
start with things that look like non-violent
fighting.
But then ten, twenty years later it becomes
a negotiation where you get what you want.
Robert: I think that's a terrific point, and
I agree with you entirely.
Although the subtitle of the book suggests
a dichotomy, in fact, the most famous article
I've ever written is called bargaining in
the shadow of the law.
Most legal conflicts are resolved through
negotiation.
But it's in the shadow of what people think
a court might do.
And often, often what you want to do is persuade
the person on the other side that you are
prepared to pursue alternatives that may be
coercive as part of a negotiation strategy.
And, so I entirely agree.
>>What do you think about the case for Libya?
There was a period of time where there was
no negotiation, and there was a period of
time there was negotiation.
Do you think that eventually negotiation was
the right thing to do with Libya?
Robert: Absolutely, in fact Libya is quite
an extraordinary example of the use of coercive
diplomacy in terms of trying to isolate Libya,
in terms of putting economic pressure on Gaddafi.
Ultimately, led to the opportunity to negotiate
with Libya.
A deal where they gave up all their aspirations
to having nuclear weapons.
And I think it was a great triumph of diplomacy.
And it illustrates the point that came up
before.
Often what you wanna do is employ a strategy
which is by some measures coercive, but also
being willing to engage.
I mean that is in fact I think what President
Obama is trying to do with Iran now in terms
of having more onerous economic sanctions
if in fact they aren't prepared to negotiate.
I must confess, I'm not terribly optimistic,
but it's certainly a mixed strategy that seems
appropriate given -- given the absence in
that case of a very good military alternative.
>>Yeah, could you speak a little bit to the
use of negotiation basically to achieve two
ends?
One is a delaying tactic in order to wait
for something else you were doing to sort
of insulate you against your opponent.
And the other is, as a tactic to divide your
opponent, if it's a group or a corporation
where by simply offering the alternative to
negotiate, you, you can split them into two
camps and prevent them from being successful
really at either one.
It seems to be a lot of time negotiations
some of these very tense situations falls
into that realm of strategy sometimes.
And if you could just speak on that a little
bit.
Robert: That's a great point, and I think
often two things.
First, parties sometimes use negotiation not
with the purpose of trying to reach a deal
at all, but as a way to play for time.
I think when the history of our negotiations
with, with Iran is written, they have brilliantly
resisted negotiations, and then when things
get a little tighter, offer a little something
more and the Europeans get very tempted and
wanna do it.
You know, in terms of trying to divide our
coalition right, and yet nothing much comes
of it.
And in the meantime, if ones cynical, you
could say they're playing for time.
They're really not interested in negotiating
an arrangement where they're gonna give up
the possibility of nuclear weapons.
Your other point is a very important point,
and it relates to a couple of the chapters
in the book.
And that is some of the most intense conflicts
are not across the table, but behind the table
within an organization, within a government.
People who were involved in arms control negotiations
during the Soviet era said negotiating with
the Soviets was patty-cake compared to the
negotiations between the Defense Department,
that State Department, the CIA, the National
Defense Agency, the various government groups
that were trying to establish what the American
negotiation posture should be.
And you're quite right that often a shrewd
negotiator can try to make offers that will
divide the adversary.
Let me give an example, it's one that --
Richard Bernstein today in the International
Herald Tribune, it's on the New York Times
website wrote an article that I was thrilled
with about my book.
Where he talks about negotiating with the
Taliban.
And he interviewed me.
And, I differentiate between three different
sorts of Taliban.
The Taliban are not an undifferentiated mass
where it's a tightly controlled group.
They're no longer in control of the government.
Some are what I call the ten dollar Taliban.
The ten dollar Taliban are those that if we
were to offer them twelve dollars might be
prepared to switch sides and lay down their
arms.
By all means we should try to do that if we
can, in my view.
Another group are regional leaders who may
not be ideologically committed to a fundamentalist
-- the imposition of an extreme form of Islam,
but who were very distressed by the corruption
in the current national government and want
various local reforms.
By all means I think we should negotiate with
these sorts as well.
But I don't think for example that it makes
a lot of sense to attempt to negotiate with
Mullah Omar and the top Taliban leadership.
Because I can imagine a deal, but I think
that deal would involve a form of power sharing
where there -- they may well regain complete
national control.
And in all events, in certain regions, it
is my belief they'd wanna shut down schools
for girls.
And make life -- and I assure you, there wouldn't
be many Google searches going on.
I mean the cosmopolitans in that segment of
Afghanistan would have a very hard time.
I don't think that's worthy of us to do at
least.
It's one thing if ultimately the Afghan government
wants to do it.
So, I offer that as you know -- I think that
when you -- looking at the other side often
there are divisions that you really want to
take into account in terms of figuring out
a reasonable strategy.
>>So, one of the things that is frequently
used rhetorically when discussing whether
or not to negotiate is the phrase madman.
Robert: Yeah
>> And it comes up in personal negotiations
as well, which is that at some point you have
to make the call that the person who you're
negotiating with, or the group you're negotiating
with is not even capable in, of acting in
what you would consider to be their self interest.
Either they're some sort of religious extremist
who's willing to blow themselves up, or they're
committed to something that makes it impossible
to negotiate with them.
How do you judge whether or not you should
negotiate or not negotiate based on whether
the person is crazy?
Robert: Two observations.
First, in the book, I end up concluding that
there should a presumption in favor of negotiation.
What negotiation involves is trying to persuade
someone else to make a deal that serves your
interests you hope very well.
And it will serve their interests better than
their alternative.
If you haven't tried to persuade, it's hard
to know whether they are susceptible to persuasion.
Okay.
And so I don't want to claim that any of us
all the time are Mr.Spock-like.And that intuition
and emotion make no difference, they do.
Indeed there are all these traps.
But on the other hand, I think people often
can be persuaded.
And can be, through a process -- think more
deeply about what's in their own long-run
interests.
And I think that opportunity should often,
as I say, should you bargain with the devil?
Not always, but more often than you feel like
it, because I think often in fact people can
be persuaded.
Where you might just assume they're crazy,
and they won't be.
That's the first point.
Second point.
Obviously there are some people who really
are a little crazy.
And whatever that might mean in different
context.
Third, and this is sort of a Thomas Schelling
game theoretical point.
As you know in terms of bargaining, to appear
to be crazy is often quite rational.
Because it may persuade you that they really
will blow themselves up and everybody else
up if I don't give them six dollars more.
Then if this deal isn't 68/32 rather than
60/40.
What do you think, someone would have to be
crazy to blow the deal up over that difference.
But in fact, if someone can persuade you that
they're crazy enough to do that through some
kind of commitment strategy prepare to do
it, that can in fact be rational.
That's what makes negotiation very interesting
in a way.
Right I mean you never quite know.
And in many negotiations with respect to distributive
aspects of bargaining, you know people end
up playing some kind of game of chicken which
is a very dangerous game to play.
Because like the old movie "Rebel Without
A Cause" sometime there's gonna be a crack-up.
You know, and somebody's gonna die, maybe
both sides will.
In teaching negotiation, I don't encourage
people to play chicken.
>>What do you think of the Nixon-Kissinger
strategy of negotiation?
Robert: You've gotta be more concrete.
>> Well you were speaking of bad men things
and press the button way of negotiation.
[Pause]
Robert: I, you may know something I don't
know.
But I'm not aware of when Kissinger threatened
to
>>For example the Christmas bombing over North
Vietnam.
The bombing of the harbor near
Robert: Yes
>>Near Hanoi right as negotiations were taking
place.
Robert: Right
Now look, I -- tactically I think there probably
were lots of mistakes made, but-- what--
Often what parties are doing is taking coercive
actions at the same time.
What they want to encourage is some kind of
negotiated agreement.
I think that probably was an example.
It often doesn't work, in fact it sometimes
just stiffens the resistance of the other
side and makes them less willing to talk.
But, that's what's going on.
And in fact, you see companies doing similar
things where they take very aggressive legal
action.
But at the same time signal the they're willing
to talk.
>>So you covered negotiations that span nearly
a century today with specific cases.
Human nature really hasn't changed that much
yet you're making your life study of negotiation.
Things have changed speed of information is
much faster than it was.
But I mean what really is changing in sort
of the field.
I know it's a little bit more open question.
Robert: Well, I, I think that's a great question.
You know, on the one hand, the flow of information,
in part because of what all of you are doing
is fantastic.
I mean, at dinner parties, I can use -- ask
Google what year Italy was unified when someone
was claiming it was 1880 and I thought it
was a little earlier.
And get the answer boom right away.
It's unbelievable, it's fantastic.
And you would think that that ought to -- I
think it does make the world better.
On the other hand, I think human conflict
is inevitable.
And the challenge is not to eliminate conflict,
because conflict can in fact be constructive.
It's to eliminate the most destructive forms
of conflict to the extent you can.
And in that regard, what I love about this
field is it's very interdisciplinary.
And human beings are very complicated creatures.
And we all have real capacity for being rational
and analytic on the one hand.
On the other hand, we all are also in terms
of decision making often driven by emotions
in ways that sometimes can lead us astray
pretty badly.
And I think in these most intense kinds of
conflicts, that's the case.
I don't think that's gonna change.
I think that we're in fact hard-wired I believe
to have one part of a brain that is very good
at rational analysis but is slow and ponderous.
But we have another part of our brain that's
very quick, very intuitive.
It will invoke early experiences, stories
we've been told, all kinds of stuff that we
may not even be conscious of.
And I think that too, can affect behavior.
So that's what makes this an interesting field.
[Pause]
>>Do you think by being willing to negotiate
and openly saying that you're willing to negotiate
you lose your ability to actually negotiate?
Robert: You lose the ability to negotiate?
>>Do you, you become weaker in your position?
Robert: you know, I, I, I guess one message
of the book is everything is contextual.
And what you have to do is think through these
series of questions.
And what their implications are in a particular
context.
For example, there are certainly situations
where I think a company would be foolish to
negotiate.
I mean for exa -- I'll give you an example
that comes up.
Someone illegally takes your property, you
know you can win the lawsuit.
You sue them, but it's gonna cost you $100,000
to pursue the litigation.
And they say, "Let's negotiate."
You know, the lawyer says, "Give me ten grand
and I'll resolve it."
Now, in the short run, settling for ten thousand
seems a lot better than spending a hundred
thousand and winning the lawsuit.
But on the other hand, if in fact your feeling
is there are hundreds of other people that
if they figure they can get a quick ten thousand
dollars by doing this will do it.
And the precedent may matter to you, and having
a reputation that you won't tolerate it can
make perfectly good sense.
So that's an example where you might be a
little tempted, but the problem is you may
be setting a precedent that in fact in the
long run isn't good for you.
And in that instance, if I were asked to advise
the company, I would say, "You shouldn't settle.
You should fight."
Well, thank you very much, it's been a great
pleasure to be here.
[Applause]